we begin in Tokyo where the leaders of
South Korea and Japan are meeting in
what's being hailed as a new milestone
in their relationship it's the first
time a South Korean leader has been
invited to Tokyo in 12 years the two
countries hope to rebuild security and
economic ties in the face of the
continued threat from North Korea
well just hours before the meeting North
Korea fired an internal intercontinental
ballistic missile into Waters between
the Korean Peninsula and Japan it's the
third missile launched by Pyongyang this
week Japan has called a National
Security Council meeting in response to
the latest test Rob McBride has more now
from Seoul on North Korea's missile
launch and the meeting of the leaders of
Japan and South Korea
this is seen as a very significant visit
it's the first time that a South Korean
president has gone on a bilateral visit
to Japan in more than 10 years president
Yun sukyol wants to restore relations
with Japan but it is a very
controversial Summit meeting which has
drawn a lot of opposition here
domestically in South Korea from
different groups protesting about
different aspects of the relationship
with Japan but president Yoon wants to
restore relations meeting with fumio
kashida the Japanese prime minister they
take a similar view politically and also
a very tough position when it comes to
North Korea wanting to re-establish
relations but there has been a lot of
pushback here politically in what is
often a very fraught relationship
between these two Neighbors
BJ Kim is a professor of international
studies at Hancock University of Foreign
Studies and a former South Korean
Diplomat he joins us now live from Seoul
good to have you with us sir so a highly
significant meeting as we heard just now
but is it going to do anything to mend
the two countries relationship
mending the relationship is not going to
happen in full scale this time with this
first visit this is going to be a
starting point but there will be a the
rose uh you know the long list of
barriers that the two countries and
especially the two leaders of the two
countries have to work together uh to
overcome uh for one here in Korea as
reported said it's uh the country is
very much divided about uh use a painful
decision to go ahead with this move and
Yoon has to come back here and work on
uh generating domestic consensus on this
and on the Japanese part as well uh
kisida had worked very hard for
producing uh you know 2015 agreement
between the two countries when he was
foreign minister and now he faces our
position and the skepticism inside Japan
saying that South Korea changes
government every several years and when
the new government the progressive
government
uh you know that's critical of this kind
of move comes into Power everything will
be changed so those skeptical voices is
pushing uh holding uh kishida back as
well so both leaders while very much
committed to improving the ties uh they
face domestic Challenge on both sides in
a geopolitical sense why is it important
that Japan and South Korea enjoy good
relations
for various reasons but the National
Security reason comes to my our minds as
the first one especially keeping in mind
in my North Korea's threat uh you know
Japan and South Korea has to work
together to work on the uh you know
North Korean missiles and nuclear
weapons threat together uh you know
going separate ways it's going to it has
a diminished both sides capability to
counter this kind of missile threats and
Japan and Korea and the United States
have to work together closely in dealing
with this threat from coming from
pyongya in terms of North Korea's latest
missile launch what is the country
trying to demonstrate right now
well you know North Korea wants to be
recognized as a power to be talked to
and they want to be invited to the table
for negotiation but while keeping their
nuclear weapons so uh you know because
they have made it very clear that
they're going to keep their nuclear
weapons they're not being invited to the
false but they want to continue to
wretch up the tensions in order to be
paid attention to in a way and you know
they want to be called upon for talks uh
they what they have in mind at this
point is not denuclear denuclearization
talk rather Arms Control talk
recognizing North Korea as a nuclear
power that's what they have in mind and
that's why they're taking all these
actions continuously almost daily basis
and you know try to provoke our side
right so they see more or less eye to
eye on North Korea but where do Japan
and South Korea stand on China
um
well China is a rising threat and both
countries recognize that and so there is
a need to work together to counter China
Japan South Korea standing alone uh just
uh cannot deal with China as effectively
as they can do together so China is an
important question in addition to North
Korea and that's why all the more the
policy makers on both sides recognize
that greater need for cooperation uh the
trilateral cooperation between Seoul
Tokyo and Russia good to talk to you
Professor many thanks indeed for being
with us BJ Kim there in Seoul thank you